contingent on to demonic this could you
affair may I once have a history of
damage a Maria say about you Johnny dead
[Music]
at only 24 years old GFX today is aboard
a 30-foot boat sailing around the world
completely on his own know what
sensitive level our ability to perceive
effexor so to the moon found I'm on
kidnapper he left bad welcome sir
the chaplain Peter Duncan captain
Jackson where's themself as you can
accumulate KQ million on the Stars
central jersey vanilla he left his home
in France two and a half years ago to
begin his journey Geneva d'espagne crazy
Phil dr. yellow resolution liquid
African in Australia
okay Eva the question I've ever known
who she is the unknown geographical area
Pasadena West
non-property later on teach Parliament
passes with Paulo Paulo no the dimeric
of it an olive oil West Germany also had
the whole to account shampoo past
experience or sewage a bucatini
Miriam Fukumoto vessel but the two sir
Messier Jinyoung Co Co most repair
although he's been navigating alone he's
found an unlikely companion she occupies
a unique so heavy that I'm cool I
remember too
not Rebecca Johnson you okayed
experiment on a VD impressive see alice
kessane Papa Panov oh man is it cool or
cannery a poor miserable life on Earth
is of Evangeline upon you
Vance I don't care Oh Tandy a canopy to
Alaska mechanic nuni on ETO reserva
commence a space probe our quarterly
Zambia profit motive a knowledge
situation typically t equal to Q so moi
ET la la Frontera so say TV on a screen
on a glass dumansky to Jericho
Takumi second viento succeed mmm
DiMaggio don't remember to appear to be
bucum someday Rocca Colonna a Varla
story is over 200 varsity alimony kupuna
Olivia welcome Oscar
[Music]
there's really no difference between
here and home it's just everything's
compacted down to a 14 by 14 room once
you start staffing your look out you're
gonna be working ten days on four days
off late June until usually mid
September it's a pretty quiet existence
this is my 24th season there's a fire
lookout and really it's just you and the
wind and the thyme just melts away
my name is leif Hagen and we're at Tomah
lookout but fire lookout is a structures
that sits on top of a mountain or ridge
top that has a good view of the
surrounding country and the staff are
then is tasked with living there for
extended periods to watch for fire it's
funny because I get a lot of questions
about the standard day you wake up with
the Sun I mean it's hard to sleep in a
room of glass much beyond sunrise first
thing I'll do is make a cup of coffee
and usually I'll have that first cup of
coffee on the front porch sit out there
watch the Sun come up
certainly every morning I go for a walk
I check in at 10:00
[Music]
hey good morning
I have 67 degrees I take the weather
every day at 2:00 and check out at 4:15
[Music]
I think the solitary nature when there's
really no fire is going the only thing I
might do is check in on the radio twice
a day that might be the only time I
really talk unless I'm talking to myself
I think what's so tricky sometimes
talking about the lookout experience is
you're not talking to anybody about it
so you more intuitive you more
experience it I think that's why I was
used a term resonance because you just
can feel it and sense it
maybe that's fanciful but it certainly
is the way I feel about it you know you
just find yourself sitting on the porch
watching the world go by for hours on
end it's it's beautiful when you look at
you know lifestyle of a fire lookout it
can be a hard choice at times too you
know I'm missing a wedding tonight over
the course of summer you might miss a
lot of stuff in your life but certainly
every summer I keep coming back because
living on top of the mountain for days
on end it's just such a beautiful chance
at making a life of it
you
[Music]
mondo bizarro sterility da da la la la
la la yo se que aunque Yahya Satan
constant a even el segundo
come on wrestle ahead
[Music]
yes show me a ganado por que pagar
bayaud que cuando nombre Koziol Cristo
enough eternal an omen a massive event a
Cinco de vacas - en nuestra cattigan
Silva de dos anos your numbers are ample
salagadoola in haben or uyama your mucho
north to the other I get the Tula
so you love another
tenemos que salir para que les love
clusters tengu mati stereo castle
entrada less a cupola illa critical ro
con una una cadena tagging or halal
Medusa no Kiribati another
you to the Royal Society was from a
castle
yes impossibly can you tell me like at
an Olympian porque de muchísimo Goffe
propellant rocket in module they stuck
at adult cuando yo era were salam on TV
that you know no ii ii ii enjoy
[Music]
Ariba gustaría dimensional a nest
ricotta de queijo importantes mommy
[Music]
the Loch Ness monster is one of our most
enduring myths people have sought its
secrets for over 1500 years but only one
man has devoted his entire life to
learning the truth alone in a van by the
Loch
and no he's not a wacko
it's just his thing my name's Steve
Felton and for the last 25 years I've
been a full-time hunter of the Loch Ness
monster I first came to lock this when I
was a seven-year-old boy and found this
set of caravans with this gang of grown
men hunting for monsters in Loch Ness
and I thought that's amazing
that would be the life for me I'd love
to do that and so he did 25 years ago he
quit his job sold his house bought this
van and pursued his passion he now holds
the Guinness record for the longest
continuous search at Loch Ness in all my
time here I've only seen one possible
sighting of something all you saw was a
spray of water off of the back of
something bok-bok-bok off like a torpedo
going shooting through to this day that
remains a mystery to me as to what that
was that was in the first year of being
here and I thought right this job's
gonna be really easy yes one sighting 25
years later I'm still sat here waiting
for that second sighting some people
think it's giant eels some people think
there's a rip in time others believe
there's a spaceship on the bottom of the
lock it's more likely to turn out to be
big catfish than a spaceship on the
bottom of the law
the reason I sit here and I try and
solve this mystery is because that's
what makes my heart sing people say is
it lifestyle or is it the mystery it's
both my life contains freedom adventure
unpredictability and the chance of one
of the world's greatest discovery should
I ever happen to find Nessie
it's a dream come true if that little
seven-year-old boy you could see what
became of him it wouldn't believe is
luck
you
we're four days walk from the nearest
road the landscapes vast the wilderness
is almost unlimited the access is by
aircraft on foot or on the right day
here you can boat it but it's a
challenge in itself
really we are at the mercy of the
weather and the tides and our day-to-day
life it's difficult living out here but
if you do what's needed and everything
comes together it's a really rewarding
place to be
[Music]
Warwick Mitchell lives in Fiordland New
Zealand's oldest and largest National
Park it covers over 12,000 square
kilometers but is home to only a few
dozen people the parks massive mountain
ranch isolates Warwick from civilization
living out here like everywhere you need
shelter a good dry camp we have solar
panel for power lighting and satellite
communications we have a quad bike we
have two boats for fishing and diving
and we have the freezer which keeps our
food and our produce cold
we rely on rainwater for drinking water
so that's not too hard with 7 meters of
rainfall annually we largely live off
the land when you're living off the land
you're really at the mercy of the
weather and the elements so there's
certain times that will allow you to go
out and harvest a deer or catch a fish
capture the menu
[Music]
if you have a down day and the waves are
really good you're more than likely
going to go surfing if the waves aren't
good but the rivers looking nice you
might catch a trout if the waves are
flat but the oceans come you might go
see fishing if the oceans stormy you
might go up the river for a kayak or go
through the bush and see if you can spot
a deer
[Music]
living in the wilderness doesn't mean
you're living in isolation from people
we certainly couldn't be doing what we
do if it wasn't for that pilots and our
neighbors and our friends whether it's
the harshness of the environment and
being so isolated that brings people
together or the fact that the people
that are willing to travel this far have
like-minded passion for the environment
and the outdoors one thing's for sure
over the years is that the communities
become really tight-knit can you go
ahead and turn this main switch on and
we'll just see if she wants to work know
when things break or things don't go
your way it's always really important to
remember you're in the green the
experiences being out here and enjoying
being out here everything else is a
bonus so you can't get too serious if
one thing breaks I don't know too many
places in the world where you can stand
on a boat looking back and you can just
see ocean leading into forests leading
into massive snow-capped mountains in
Glacier shaped Bay's with pristine
rivers and clear water the trees are as
they were 200 years ago and the people
that I bring out here they get to
experience this nature as it was and as
it should be and we try to keep the area
and the environment pristine in this
little corner of New Zealand
you
[Music]
you